uh she's a repeat speaker both at our
gov and at nyr
and she's apparently disaffected of her
current job
because she wants a different job her
dream her dream job would be a panda
caretaker by day but she had to Learn
Python to do
and then a at-home restaurateur at night
so pandas and restaurants we don't know
what type of Cuisine it is you need to
tell us
Moroccan like that you know I hope you
know that uh so everyone please welcome
asthma
awesome well hello everyone thank you so
much for braving the cold and being here
um asthma to me and I'm the director of
analytics and research at Pursuit care
today I want to talk to you about how
we're leveraging open source and
professional our tools to deliver
evidence-based care for our patients
uh so Jared mentioned I am a repeat
speaker my first talk was discussing our
experience as a startup and I'm excited
to talk to you guys about the progress
that we've made we're now in our third
year of operation
so first I'd like to begin the talk uh
by discussing the crisis we're facing
so for over two decades now we've faced
worsening rates of mental illness which
have had devastating medical social and
economic consequences at the individual
and societal level
from
1999 to 2019 nearly half a million
people died from an overdose involving
any opioid which includes prescriptions
and illicit drugs
the number of drug overdose deaths has
quadrupled since 1999.
just to put it into perspective that's
about 136 people dying every day
or about a person every five minutes
so this crisis has only gotten worse
during the ongoing covid-19 pandemic
after an already catastrophic increase
in 2020 deaths have risen to a new
record in 2021.
mortality data from the national Vital
Statistics system show that we've gone
from a new record last April of 75 000
deaths in a time span of a year to a
hundred and eight thousand in the last
year
newer provisional data which isn't shown
here suggests that Most states have
faced an additional increase of about
six percent Nationwide due to reporting
lags this actually might be an
underestimate
so this rise in overdose deaths can be
seen across the country with some states
experiencing as much as 50 60 70 percent
increase in deaths and it continues to
worsen in many areas
only a handful have had decreases and
given where we're gathered today or
close to it Maryland Maryland is on
track to have its second or third year
of steady decreases and not sure if
anyone in the crowd is involved with
that work but I know firsthand how
difficult it is and they should be proud
of their efforts
unfortunately Most states are not in
this boat as we can see and the reasons
for these steep increases are complex
and very in nature from region to region
it's true that the pandemic has
exacerbated
many inequalities across racial ethnic
and socioeconomic class
it's also worsened access to care as
many in-person clinics closed or
decrease operations
some clinics never truly bounced back
leading to even further fragmented care
even in this environment of Lucent
restrictions
one very important factor behind this
worsening crisis is the sheer inadequate
number of resources available to
patients so in a recent 2022 study it
was found that among 3 200 counties in
America
78 had no in-person treatment program
um 29 percent
did not have any clinicians that can
dispense life-saving medications for
people struggling with addiction
so we know people are seeking care
um but simply they cannot find it in a
way that is convenient destigmatized or
affordable
maybe I should keep going with no slides
um a little hard to do but
um
so the person sorry I don't even throw
up trying to fix this okay
the first year we've had VCR
um
and because it's fine
go ahead problem fixed awesome thank you
uh so an added difficulty to all of this
is the access to these life-saving
medications that we just spoke about
which continues to be difficult really
indiscriminately of person across sex
age race and ethnicity however these
disparities according to a recent study
are most severe for folks that are black
Hispanic
um this is hardly surprising as we know
these populations face tremendous
barriers to care due to systemic racism
fragmented care insufficient medical
staff and under-resourced areas
an additional stigma of course related
to their use of drugs
so I work at Pursuit care and at the
heart of what we do is trying to
eliminate every barrier that we can to
care this is why we leverage Telehealth
technology to meet patients wherever
they are
it allows us to meet patients who don't
have adequate local resources and who
need treatment really fast
we also offer in-person care in New
Jersey and Pennsylvania
and we're proud to have staff local
staff there that have intimate knowledge
of the Dynamics of the crisis on a local
level which allows us to make good on
our promise to deliver culturally
competent care as much as we can
so in person and virtually we're able to
treat all substance use disorders like
opioid use disorder alcohol use disorder
and other severe mental illnesses
the flexibility of Telehealth not only
allows for same-day treatment but it
also allows us to implement
functionality through our app that we've
developed that keeps our patients
engaged in their treatment and their
recovery
currently our platform allows for
medication-assisted treatment one-on-one
with providers psychiatric care
individual and group therapy
FDA approved digital Therapeutics and we
also have our own Pharmacy
our goals in the data science team is to
broadly speaking help our organization
take better care of our patients and we
have a couple goals that guide us
through that
one of them being better understanding
our patients so that begins with
detecting Trends with the lens of where
they are how they see care and once
they're in our care are they meaning
their milestones
this involves the continual monitoring
of their outcomes for the purposes of
implementing procedural changes and
personalized treatments
we also monitor the outcomes of those
process changes and try to detect any
new emerging Trends from those
so how do we accomplish this uh well it
starts with a robust internal tooling
so we're bootstrapped we're a small team
of two data Engineers me and a data
analyst and we spend a large amount of
time configuring reconfiguring and
optimizing our stack for efficiency and
automation
so being in a startup in a in its third
year now we're cautious of right sizing
our tools to reduce overhead costs and
use our team in the most efficient and
productive way possible
um a significant pain point in
healthcare is just the explosion of
vendors that you will have to deal with
which service Us in different ways we
have a vendor for electronic health
record we have a vendor for lab results
we have a vendor for our insurance
claims and financial data and the
challenge here is marrying all those
data sources together to better
understand our practice and our patients
so we we invest heavily in the
maintenance of our data warehouse which
houses almost all of our vendors data
and is augmented also by publicly
available data summarized from the
American Census Bureau and the CDC so we
can enable the data science team but
also our internal and external
stakeholders to understand how social
determinants of Health are impacting our
patients which then helps us to
implement more personalized treatments
and more culturally competent procedural
changes
so as we've said we continue to invest a
lot into our data warehouse and it was
important for us to have control over it
and not rely on vendors own data which
sometimes did provision us with reading
database access but I believe we've
saved
enormous time and proactively avoided
many pitfalls by having our own
namely to always have this always on
monitoring surveillance reporting and
error detection
and we've also cut down significantly on
confusion over what certain Fields mean
coming from the Myriad of data sources
from our vendors so with that in mind
we've designed our own grammar or
vocabulary for naming data fields and
this allowed really our entire team
to better communicate and better
collaborate and this has had
trickle-down effects from the data
warehouse to our internal packages which
also uses the same naming conventions
and it allows us to be faster at writing
code for everyday data wrangling tasks
foreign
speaking of internal packages uh we've
taken the time to develop and refine
sort of our internal stack beginning
with
ETL processes DB connections and queries
a new one that we've developed this year
is data validation we were very heavily
inspired by the point blank package
which helps us do regular data quality
assessments
and finally we're continuing to refine
our data manipulation and data
visualization and internal packages for
common repeated steps that we do
and so all of that internal tooling
helps us with better understanding our
patients detecting Trends and being on
top of any data quality issues that
arise
now in terms of monitoring our outcomes
we have four that we
um
check on and develop models for on a
regular basis so both the data science
team and our internal stakeholders work
together to establish these and they
involve engagement meaning engagement
with our care and our app
retention and care how long do they stay
engaged with us their drug use or lack
thereof and adherence to their treatment
plan as set out by their expert
providers
while some outcomes are you know derived
by simple counting and grouping the
majority do involve some additional lift
due to the nature of the data and the
complexity of the analyzes so we make
very heavy use of the Tidy verse tidy
models brms and some causal inference
packages
so how do we actually deliver these
analyzes to the stakeholders in a way
that balances ease of use maximum
Insight but without overwhelming the
viewer
and we found that an approach of
carefully curated reports spanning
non-overlapping facets of an analysis is
uh successful for us
and we found that these two serve us
very well for our purpose
um I was very intrigued by Charli's talk
on Cordo but I'm not quite ready to make
that jump uh maybe when we have a more
multilingual team but for now we are 100
in our shop
and so we make heavy use of our markdown
uh for several advantages that I'm sure
the audience is very well aware of but
we do make heavy use of it for our more
static reports and for simulations and
modeling work we tend to make use of
shiny for a more Dynamic experience
and we love using our markdown because
it's flexibility is great in organizing
chunks by the purpose that they serve
I know personally firsthand that some of
my earlier reports were not the best
constructed so having that flexibility
to change it refine it all in a
reproducible and version controlled way
is really powerful and the flexibility
of the outputs have allowed us to
quickly iterate over reports based on
stakeholder feedback
and the portability is great too as we
know uh it can be published on a
publishing platform
um it can be a PowerPoint document so it
really spans
um many many
um different ways to publish your
results
and a recent and really exciting
addition to our workflow is the use of
the pins package and admittedly I've
been kind of sleeping on this for too
long but for those who are unfamiliar
it's an awesome package designed to
share and publish data models and most
are objects by quote unquote pinning it
to a board
this is really perfect for our use case
because we often need to reuse data and
uh track changes in those data sets and
running historical point-in-time
analyzes so this has really allowed us
to move completely away from storing any
point in time data in Excel or shared
Drive which is a win in my book
and so that's all good but how do we
actually get our results from our local
machines onto the hands of our
stakeholders so it was immediately clear
for us in the beginning that our studio
connect now known as posit connect made
a lot of sense given that our entire
workflows were built in r with a
Microsoft Azure backend but we've been
impressed over time with its flexibility
and ease of use for all our staff and
this is really reflected in our usage
data that we can take a look into and
posit connect and I'm so proud by the
way the staff no matter what technical
savviness level use it and give us
feedback
so I think this is really what it's all
about for me
um my role is to make this a truly data
driven and evidence-based company and I
feel like these tools truly allow me and
our team to do that
so with that being said thank you I
appreciate your time if you have any
questions please hit me up email Twitter
thanks